ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
My name is Artur Oliveira, and I
am on the Talks at Google team.
I am very excited to welcome
to Google today the great actor
and comedian Rainn Wilson.
He's here to talk
about his new memoir
"The Bassoon King-- My Life
in Art, Faith, and Idiocy."
Now, we all know Rainn as
the lovable Dwight Schrute
from NBC's "The Office."
But the thing is that
through "The Bassoon King,"
Rainn really lets us
know who he really is
and what his career
has been like.
So with that, I would love
to welcome up Rainn Wilson.
[APPLAUSE]
RAINN WILSON: Thanks, Artur.
Hello.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thank you very
much for coming to Google.
RAINN WILSON: Hey,
thanks for having me.
I love it here.
This is great.
Free food.
Sign me up.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: We're very
happy that you're here.
Like I said in the intro,
we all love "The Office,"
but I think what
I especially loved
about "The Bassoon
King" is really getting
to know your life story.
And what was really
interesting to me,
what I wanted to start off
with, is it's easy for us
to see people who are famous
and think that they just did it.
The snapped their fingers,
and they got on a TV show,
they got in a movie,
whatever it is.
But you talk so much about the
ups and downs of your career.
What made you want
to make yourself so
vulnerable with the audience?
RAINN WILSON: Well,
I did research,
and I had read a lot of
celebrity memoirs when I was
getting ready to write this,
because I wanted to see what
worked and what didn't.
And one of the things that
I thought did not work
was memoirs where I read,
and I didn't know the person
at the end of the
memoir any more
than I did at the beginning.
What I responded to, personally,
were the heartfelt stories,
the vulnerabilities, the
struggles, the ups and downs,
the roller coaster ride
that the person went on.
And those are the things
that I could relate
to and kind of learn from.
And I also found them
to be the funniest,
because they struck a nerve.
They struck a deeper chord.
So I swung for the fences.
I really was like, I want
this-- I'm going to write one.
This is who I am and
this is what I'm about.
And if I walk out here
on Charleston and get
hit by a bus, and
this is the document
that-- it's got everything.
It's all my failures
and struggles,
and I get hit by the Google bus.
No one will even look up
from their Wi-Fi computers,
they'll be like--
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: That
would be very tragic.
There's got to be someone
here who runs the buses.
They're just kind of panicking
in the back of the room
somewhere.
RAINN WILSON: But if I
was hit by a Google car,
it would be going
seven miles an hour,
so I'd probably
knock the car over.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thanks
for explaining that.
Does that also tie in to why
you decided to write it now?
Why not 20 years from now?
RAINN WILSON: Well, there
was a window of time,
and it just seemed like
the right opportunity.
I finished "The Office,"
and right away I
shot a pilot for
the show "Backstrom"
that ran on Fox for a little
while before it was canceled.
One person whistled.
One person groaned,
because no one watched it.
And then I had this
nice chunk of time,
and I thought, well,
this is a time to do it.
Actually, I was here at
Google maybe five years ago,
where we read from
our SoulPancake book,
"SoulPancake-- Chew on
Life's Big Questions."
When I wrote the
introduction of that book,
I saw that there was a
story there that I really
wanted to tell.
Yeah, there's the funny stories
of worms coming out of my butt
in Nicaragua, and being a
starving actor and broke
and struggling, and trying
to make my way in LA,
and being a nerd
in high school--
I know there's a lot
of funny stories.
But there's also a through line
of my spiritual and artistic
journey that I
thought made it a book
and not just a collection
of funny anecdotes.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Absolutely.
It's a very cohesive story
from beginning to end,
and we can see your
growth as a person
and as an actor
throughout the book, which
is why I'm so excited for
everyone to be able to read it.
So now taking a step
back, I think we're all
wondering about the name.
Why "The Bassoon King"?
RAINN WILSON: Well, I played
the bassoon for five years
in junior high and high school.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Do
you still play it?
RAINN WILSON: No.
I dug one out about
five or six days ago,
because I had to play it
on "The Colbert Show."
I hadn't played a
bassoon in 30 years.
But I have a little
section here I'm
going to read about the
bassoon, and about being
nerdy in high school.
Maybe a few of you can relate.
A couple, one or
two of you, might
be able to relate just a
teeny, teeny little bit.
All right, ready, children?
"I ask you to savor
the following sentence.
For several years off
and on, I was a member
of the following clubs at
school-- marching band,
pep band, orchestra, debate
club, computer club, chess
club, model United
Nations, and pottery club.
Note the above list does not
include my aforementioned role
playing gaming, Baha'i youth
activities, medieval weapons
sketching, kung fu movie
obsession, or vast Columbia
Record and Tape Club
cassette collection,
featuring Journey, Styx,
Asia, and REO Speedwagon.
And then, if that wasn't enough,
I decided to play the bassoon.
Boom, universe explodes, then
implodes, then explodes again,
quickly folding
in on itself, only
to create infinite other
bassoon-shaped universes.
Let's dig a little
deeper, shall we?
Having studied piano as
a kid and then clarinet
at Kellogg Middle School,
I went to my band teacher
and told him I wanted to quit
clarinet and play tenor sax.
Saxophone was way
cooler, you see.
Guys in the sax section
would crack jokes and wear
sunglasses in class sometimes.
Clarinet wasn't
pathetically loserish--
I mean, it wasn't French
horn-- but it certainly
wasn't the most
masculine of instruments.
Sure, there was a clarinet-like
instrument in the Cantina scene
in "Star Wars,"
but let's face it.
Clarinets are for
girls in braces
and Woody Allen, who loves
girls in braces, ba-bum, bum.
My band teacher, John
Law-- real name--
really pulled a fast one on me.
He said something to
the effect of, well,
you could play the sax, but
we've got so many saxophones
right now.
Wait a minute-- he paused
for dramatic effect
and lowered his voice
conspiratorially-- you know
what's really cool and unique?
And I was like, what?
What's really cool and unique?
And he was like, the bassoon.
And I was like,
wow, what's that?
And with that
ridiculous manipulation,
a bassoonist was born.
The bassoon is absurd.
They should be banned for
being horrible, unnecessary,
and adenoidally grating.
It takes, like, an
hour to assemble one.
They're enormous,
and are made out
of Lincoln logs, aluminum
twigs, and paper towel tubes.
There are these tiny
double wooden reeds
that you have to soak and
trim and tend to all the time.
There's a strap
that you actually
have to sit on when you play
so the whole thing doesn't
fall onto the floor like
a bundle of garbage.
And after all that
folderol, it ends up
sounding like an anemic
donkey with laryngitis.
I ended up playing the bassoon
for the next five years
until I graduated high school.
For better or worse,
I spent my adolescence
tethered to that bastard
woodwind, my siren, my spirit
animal, my nerd crucifix."
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Bravo.
[APPLAUSE]
RAINN WILSON: No, really.
No, really.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I'm confident
you just transported everyone
here back to middle school.
RAINN WILSON: A
little bit, right?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
I think the title
of the book-- in and of itself
it's a microcosm of the book,
because you have "The
Bassoon King," a fun title.
But you also have the
subtitle-- "My Life
in Art, Faith, and Idiocy."
And I really like
how in the beginning,
in the special
thanks section, you
thank your dad for teaching
you about art and faith.
Could you talk a little
bit more about your dad
and the relationship you
had with him growing up?
Because you have so
many beautiful anecdotes
you share about your
relationship with him
and the influence he had on you.
RAINN WILSON: Yeah.
So I talked about the
faith aspect of it,
which is a little bit risky
too, because people don't really
talk about faith.
Or they don't do
it in a way that's
funny and a little bit
edgy, like I'm trying to.
But I grew up a member
of the Baha'i faith,
and my dad was a Baha'i.
And the way he wove
his spiritual belief
and his creativity together
were really inspiring.
So my dad was an
aspiring painter.
He paints abstract
oil paintings.
And they were always in our
house, stacked to the ceiling
and hung on all the walls, and
then he'd swap them out every
once in a while.
He wasn't very good
at selling them,
but he was really
good at painting them.
And he also wrote tons of
science fiction and fantasy
novels while I was growing up.
So he worked in a sewer
contracting office in Seattle,
but he would pound away on a
little manual typewriter when
he wasn't answering
phones, or doing billing,
or sewer truck dispatching.
He wrote, like, 10 or 12 fantasy
and science fiction novels,
so that was very inspiring.
He always encouraged me
to be creative and extend
my imagination.
And he was a very devoted
member of the Baha'i faith,
and was always trying to kind
of deepen his spirituality
at the same time.
So those are some things
I'm really grateful for.
On the more negative
side, it was also
the fact that he was
kind of a failed artist,
that he wasn't able to achieve
his dream as an artist.
He was supporting the family
and working day jobs and stuff,
so he didn't get to
really pursue it.
That also helped me
to become an actor,
because I saw what
could happen to someone
who wanted to be an
artist but wasn't
able to or willing to commit
completely into that world.
So when I made that
decision to become an actor,
it was a very serious decision.
I knew that I was
going to be needing
to commit 10 years
of my life, at least,
to intensive training,
and studying with the very
best people, and
calling myself an actor,
and really pursuing that dream,
and committing whole hog.
You can't just do
it on the side.
So in a way he
also showed me what
not to do if you
wanted to be an artist.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I love that
journey, and how he helped
you really make
the decision to go
to NYU, to really invest in that
part of who you wanted to be.
I also wanted to ask, as
far as the next generation,
you talk a lot about how
nerdy you were growing up,
and you played
Dungeons and Dragons,
and you read fantasy
and science fiction.
Is your son following
in your nerdy footsteps?
RAINN WILSON:
Well, that's funny.
He's 11 years old, Walter, and
it's such a different landscape
then to now.
When I was a nerd in the
late '70s and early '80s,
it was a very different place.
There were no nerd television
shows and nerd CEOs,
and there was no Silicon Valley,
and there was no Bill Gates,
there was no Beck, there
was no nerd rock stars.
It didn't exist.
You were really the
lowest on the totem pole.
I remember even the
teachers would get in on it.
There was no concept
of stopping bullying.
Are you kidding me?
Bullying is good for you.
It toughens you up, it gives you
wisdom, and it lets you grow.
It was a positive thing.
And so teachers growing
up-- I remember,
some kid with zits in the
corner did something stupid
and picked his
nose, or something.
The teacher's like, yeah,
you should kick the crap out
of him.
He picked his nose in class.
I hope you do.
Anyway, turn your pages to--
It was a very different world.
And nerds were reviled.
It just was a matter of course--
you're going to get punched,
and you're going
to get made fun of.
And that's just how it is.
It's different now.
My son is in school,
and he does it all.
So he plays Dungeons and
Dragons with his friends
on the weekend, and then he's
on the flag football team.
There doesn't seem to be
any kind of issue with that.
He really geeks out about
science fiction movies
and stuff like that, and
music, and at the same time,
he's well liked.
So I think it's a better
time by and large.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
Better way to grow up.
You talk a lot-- you
go on, respectfully,
a little bit of a rant
in the book about how
being geeky and nerdy
is now considered cool.
You mentioned the nerdy CEOs,
and TV shows, Silicon Valley,
and everything.
What do you think has
caused that cultural shift?
Is it the importance
of technology
and these things in society?
Is it just purely
money and marketing?
RAINN WILSON: I think there's
a lot of different factors.
A couple is we went from a
manufacturing-based economy
to an information-based economy
over the course of 20 years,
less than one generation.
And I also think that
capitalism is king,
and the capitalists swiftly
realized, hey, wait a minute.
These nerds are
making some money.
And they'll spend that money,
and they'll tell their friends
to spend that money on movies
and on gadgets and everything.
So they used to kind of be
shunned, but let's co-opt them.
So the whole nerd/geek thing
is kind of overly talked about.
But a lot of it just has
to do with how can we suck
the nerds dry of their cash?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Do
you still play D&D?
RAINN WILSON: I don't
play D&D anymore.
I don't have the time.
I would love to.
I would love to, there's
nothing against it.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: That's great.
I think the great
thing about hearing
you talk about that
at Google is the fact
that for the most part,
almost all of us in this room
were on a similar boat to
a greater or lesser degree
while growing up.
And it's great to be able
to identify with someone who
had that same experience, and
as you said, kind of climbed
the ladder of nerd-dom
in high school
until you made it
to theater, and you
were at the top of that ladder.
RAINN WILSON: I call the
theater geeks the lions
of the nerd Serengeti.
Theater's at the top
because there are actually
cute girls in the theater, who
if you make them laugh enough,
they will potentially
make out with you.
I transferred high schools
from Seattle to Chicago
and they had a good
theater department there,
and I did this-- I have a
chapter called "How Elvis
Costello Made Me an Actor."
Because they had an exercise
called private in public.
It's a very common theater
exercise where you just
act out as if you're
in your bedroom,
and people are just watching.
So I put on Elvis
Costello's "Mystery Dance"
off of "My Aim Is True."
This was in 1982.
And I just started
thrashing around, pretending
I was in my bedroom just
goofing off to the song,
and lip syncing it and stuff.
And it brought the house down.
I had recently moved
into that school.
And then all the
girls, at the end,
they were like, oh,
you're so funny.
Will you sit at our lunch table?
You should try out
for the next play!
And I was just like, huh,
girls have talked to me.
So I left the others-- model
United Nations, chess team,
forget it.
It was done.
I was in.
And eventually, met my wife.
We were drama geeks at
University of Washington
together and ended
up dating later on,
and now have been
together for 25 years.
So good things can happen.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: You've
talked about the art part,
and I want to get to the faith.
But I can't not ask you about
the idiocy of the title.
Why did you choose to
include that in the title,
and what do you mean by that?
RAINN WILSON: Well,
part of the idiocy
is just the stupid
things that I've done
and the things that
I've experienced.
I wanted to really make
myself vulnerable in the book.
I think that's the only
way to do a book like this.
So there's a lot of things I
end up looking pretty stupid.
I've made a lot of mistakes
on this road, of all kinds.
You know, it's not
really an idiocy thing,
but one of the
chapters is called
"How I Bombed on
Broadway." and I
think it's a very telling
story at the center.
Because I was out of acting
school for a few years,
and I was working as an
actor, and I got cast
in my first Broadway show.
It was at the Roundabout
Theatre Company on Broadway.
And it was kind of an English
restoration, stylized comedy
of manners type of thing.
And I sucked.
I was terrible in it.
I got really stuck early on
in the rehearsal process.
I always have had this
issue, this character defect,
of just wanting approval and
wanting people to like me.
So I got cast and I had
these thoughts like, oh, I
could get a Tony nomination.
I could get a great
"New York Times" review.
I could get a great agent.
I could get
discovered from this.
I had all these
visions of sugar plums.
And I got really
stuck in the role.
I couldn't get out of it.
I was just bad.
I was very robotic
and stiff, and it just
ended up not being good.
And I went through hell.
I'd call my wife at
3:00 in the morning
and sob to her about it.
And I just couldn't
get out of it,
and it was eating me up inside.
And then when I finished
that, I remember going out
on 44th Street near
Broadway in New York,
and I was like, you know what?
F it.
I'm not ever going
to do that again.
Whatever just happened,
I'm not going to do it.
It's just too hard.
I can't be some
external idea of what
it is to be a New York actor,
wanting approval, wanting
to be liked, thinking
I needed to be
something outside of myself.
All of that stuff, I
just really jettisoned.
I was like, I'm a quirky
guy, I'm an oddball,
this is who I am.
I need to play roles
that are like that.
I need to use who I am
in those kind of roles.
And that's when
I started slowly,
slowly having more
and more success.
So when I look back on it,
it was a horrible experience.
Bombing on Broadway
and getting bad reviews
and sucking in front
of 1,000 people
every night for three months or
four months, it really sucks.
Trust me.
And yet had I not
gone through that,
I never would have
played Dwight.
I wouldn't have had the tools,
I wouldn't have had the skill
set and the belief
in myself to play
such an odd, quirky
character that draws
on a lot of my own odd quirks.
So I think that's
how life works.
You can look at it as
a psychological lesson,
a sociological lesson, a
spiritual lesson, if you like.
But those fires and
those tests, often time
when you get the luxury of
looking back on your life
and having written a
memoir, which is something
I recommend for everyone,
whether you're on TV or not,
to write one.
Because it's a really
interesting perspective
to look back on your life, and
you see how it was those tests
that make us who we are.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: And that was
not too far from the time
when you started going back
to your Baha'i childhood faith
and started incorporating
it back into your life.
And you talk a lot in the book,
and also in "SoulPancake,"
about spirituality, and
how that's no longer
a cool word in society.
And you wanted to bring that
back and have people discuss
the big questions in life.
Why did you feel like that?
Because that's
different from acting.
What drew you to that, too,
in addition to the acting
that you were doing at the time?
RAINN WILSON: Well,
that's where I'll
disagree with you a little bit.
What I came to realize is it's
not different than acting.
In our culture,
spirituality right now
is this very separate thing.
It has to do with church.
It has to do with
fundamentalist religion,
or else it has to do with some
kind of very vague, new agey
kind of yoga pants and crystals
and how I'm feeling today
and my aura kind of bullshit.
When spirituality really
is based in truth,
in the truth of the human
condition-- and it's
a set of skills and tools
that one uses in one's life
to understand how to navigate
life better, but also what
gives us meaning and
what gives us purpose
and what moves us forward.
So I view it more like that.
But I used to view art-- when
I was starting SoulPancake,
Ed Helms came up and was like,
hey Rainn, doo-doo doo-doo.
What's this SoulPancake
thing you're starting?
I was like, well, it
kind of blends creativity
and spirituality.
And he was like, aren't those
things mutually exclusive?
And I think that that's
a very common misnomer.
I think if you look
at human history,
the spiritual and the artistic
has always been blended,
whether it's shamans in
a cave telling a story,
whether it's Michelangelo
working on the Sistine Chapel.
It's John Coltrane
creating his work
that he saw as this
divine prayer, played
through his saxophone.
It is a key teaching
in the Baha'i faith
that art and devotion
are synonymous,
especially art done in
the spirit of service.
If you're doing art
in service to others--
because whatever
you're doing in service
is really an act of worship,
maybe the most powerful act
of worship that you can have.
So yeah, it was a
long journey for me.
Having lost faith, I
moved to New York City.
I just wanted to be a Bohemian.
I didn't want any morality.
I just wanted to do
what I wanted to do,
when I wanted to do it, and I
wanted to live that Bohemian
lifestyle.
And then as I became
an actor, I found
myself very dissatisfied
in my life, which
didn't make any sense
to me, because I
was working as an actor.
I was a professional actor.
Why do I feel alienated
and discontent inside?
What's going on with this?
And then I thought, well, maybe
by discarding God and faith,
I had thrown out the
baby with the bathwater.
So I started a very long--
it was like a eight year
journey of exploring
God and faith.
And I read the holy
books of the world,
and started having
discussions with people,
and kind of digging into
life's big questions
in a more vital way.
And that eventually, over
years, brought me back
to the faith of my childhood.
I decided that that made
the most sense to me,
and it also brought me the most
focus and the most serenity.
So that's part of
the story as well.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thanks.
I really appreciate
you explaining that.
And I think the
parts in the book
where you talk about that
aspect of spirituality
were some of my favorites.
Thanks so much for
talking with me.
I would love, if you would,
if we could turn it over
to the audience--
RAINN WILSON: No.
[LAUGHTER]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
--ask some questions.
We have a microphone
in the back for you,
so if you could please
make sure to use it.
And while you're
lining up and while we
get our first question,
I have one last question
for your, Rainn.
We all love "The Office."
How much of you is in Dwight,
and how much of Dwight
is in you?
RAINN WILSON: That's
what she said.
[LAUGHTER]
RAINN WILSON: Well, I get
asked that question a lot.
I don't really know
how to answer it.
I can certainly be
a dick at times.
I'm pretty different than
Dwight, I have to say.
Real answer-- jokey
answers, blah blah
blah-- I'm not
like Dwight at all.
I'm not regimented and
disciplined and rigorous
with a set of
hierarchical rules.
And I'm not a toady.
And sometimes I can be
a little self-serious,
but I'm not self-serious
in the way that he is.
His whole clannishness around
his family in the Schrute
system is not at all how I am.
I'd like to think that I'm
more emotionally sensitive.
But you know, I'm
definitely quirky.
I think there's a little
Dwight in all of us.
That's what she said.
[LAUGHTER]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: All right.
Well, thank you.
If we could go to the back.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
So actually tying into
that, my first question
is what type of bear is best?
RAINN WILSON: That's an
interesting question.
I think I'm going to go with
the Himalayan sun bear, which
has never been brought
up on "The Office"
before, because they're
really the bear that's most
in need of protection from us.
That was my anti-Dwight answer.
AUDIENCE: Well then, Dwight
would say, false, black bear.
RAINN WILSON: False, black bear.
AUDIENCE: But in all
seriousness, do you have
a favorite part of the book?
And if so, which is it and why?
RAINN WILSON: Do I have a
favorite part of the book?
That's a great question.
I think that I've been over
some of my favorite parts.
I think my favorite
part of the book
is towards the end, when I
start talking about SoulPancake
and the founding of that
media company with my friends,
and also the work that my wife
and I do in Haiti and some
of the arts education that
we do for adolescent girls
in rural Haiti.
Because it really
is a culmination
of so much of what I've
gone through and learned
through my life have resulted
in these things, have resulted
in SoulPancake, which is a
constant exploration of what
it is to be a human being.
Life's big questions, inspiring
content, uplifting content,
bringing people together.
It combines the spiritual
with the creative,
and the same with
the work in Haiti.
So that's been nice to see
that the things that I'm
most engaged in in
my life right now
are a culmination of and
reflection of my life's journey
to this point.
AUDIENCE: Very cool.
RAINN WILSON: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
RAINN WILSON: Anyone else?
I that it?
One question.
AUDIENCE: You've had
such an incredible career
with this longevity
with "The Office"
and your books and everything.
Is there something that
you haven't done yet
that you really want to do?
RAINN WILSON: Yeah,
there's a number of things
that I want to do.
I have a couple movies that
I'd really like to direct.
I haven't directed a movie.
I'd also really love to
do a great of Broadway
run in a role, to
have that experience.
I've been on Broadway
a couple of times.
But to go back and
have a really good role
and experience a Broadway run
is a really exciting thing
to do as an actor.
You know, take the
subway in, and go
to the theater, and
the half-hour call,
and people coming in and
being in these houses that
are 120 years old that
Barrymore used to act in.
It's a really fun thing.
Those are a couple
things I'd like to do.
AUDIENCE: I guess the
followup to that is, what
is that dream role on Broadway?
What did you grow up
with, like, oh my god, I
would love to do that.
RAINN WILSON: "Larry
Page-- The Musical."
[LAUGHTER]
Any other questions?
MALE SPEAKER: One over here.
We'll pass it to you.
Can we pass it to him?
No?
AUDIENCE: How does it work
with the writers on a show
like "The Office"?
How did you go about
creating Dwight?
Was it a written part that
then you put your stamp on,
or did you guys exchange ideas?
How do you create that and
collaborate with the writers?
RAINN WILSON: So the word
that you used, collaborate,
is really the best word.
I mean, there wouldn't be
Dwight without the writers,
and without Greg
Daniels especially.
He really is the super
genius behind the whole show.
First of all, our "Office"
was based on the BBC "Office,"
so Gareth was an
amazing creation.
And there's just so
much stuff that I
did as Dwight that
just was taken
from Gareth, stolen
from Mackenzie Crook
and him playing Gareth.
And then I had
conversations with Greg
about what he was
thinking about Dwight.
He wrote a really
great email early on.
I need to find that email.
I wrote him an email.
I said, I'm worried
that Dwight's just
kind of going to be
the annoying, geeky guy
in the office.
What can we do to kind
of change that up,
and give him more textures
and layers and nuance?
And he wrote this beautiful
essay about Dwight, and how
he sees the world,
and his hierarchies,
and his love of order, and his
family, and stuff like that.
I have to find that
essay somewhere.
But for instance, early
on in the first season,
there was no hint of Dwight
being on a farm or anything
like that.
And I did in
improvisation where I
said, just completely
off the cuff, I was like,
"My name is Dwight Schrute.
My father's name
is Dwight Schrute.
His father's name?
Dwide Shrude-- Amish."
And all of a sudden, there
was this Amish connection,
and they were like,
oh that's cool.
And that led to, eventually, the
beat farm, and the Amishness,
and Mose, and the
bed and breakfast.
It came out of an improv, so
there was a give and take.
And that was one of the great
things about "The Office."
I have a friend on a
big sitcom right now,
and they're not allowed
to improvise at all.
I mean, if it says, um,
uh, yeah, hello, you
can't even say, um, OK, hello.
You're doing a
comedy, and you have
to say every line as scripted.
And "The Office" was
very collaborative,
which I really appreciated.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thanks
so much for coming.
I saw you when you were
here last, five years ago.
RAINN WILSON: Oh, nice.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
what was your experience writing
the book, taking so much time
to just reflect and look back
and sort of process your life?
How was the experience of
it, and has it changed at all
how you live now?
RAINN WILSON: That's
a good question.
Technology's the
number one enemy
to trying to get
anything creative done.
And maybe you guys find
that-- you work in technology,
but I imagine your emails
and your Twitter feed
are your number one enemy to
try doing programming or design,
or whatever it is you're doing.
I would turn the Wi-Fi
off on my computer.
What I really wanted to
do was get a computer
without any Wi-Fi,
so it was just
like I was-- but it was great.
It was very meditative.
I realized that my only
creative hours were really
between like 9:00 and 12:30.
After that my brain was mush.
And in that period of
time, I could write
between 400 and 1,000 words.
If you do that every day, If
you write 1,000 words a day
for 300 days, then
you've got 300,000 words.
Is that right?
That's too much words.
See, this is why I'm
not in programming.
But you can write a book.
You know what I mean?
You can write a book.
So it was a great process of
looking back on your life.
And it was the first
time I really made myself
that disciplined to
sit down every day
and put down those number
of words on the page.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So since faith and spirituality
is a big part of your book,
I was wondering what your
personal definition of God is.
RAINN WILSON: That's
a great question,
because I think that that's
where people get really
hung up.
I also joke that it's really
am anathema for a comedian
to talk about God
or spirituality.
First of all, other
comedians are just like, ugh.
They don't know how
to deal with it.
And I love talking about topics
that really clear the room,
like God and death.
You bring up, so what
do you think about God?
Uh, excuse me, I got to go.
It really creeps people out.
Recently, I said on one
of these book tour things,
the most punk rock thing
that someone could do
is talk about God
and spirituality.
Because it is the thing that
just unsettles people more
than anything else.
But one of the things we
tried to do at SoulPancake
was really redefine
the idea of God.
Because that's where
people get really hung up.
It's the god of
their grandfathers,
or it's a judgmental old man
on a cloud with a beard who's
really judgmental and
scowling and disapproving,
and hates people of this faith
and loves people of the other.
But for me it was when
I started researching
Native American
spirituality, and I
found this concept
of Wakan Tanka
from the Lakota
Sioux idea of God.
And the name
literally translates
as "the great mystery."
And when I started
thinking about God
as the great mystery--
sure, a creator,
sure, all-loving, sure, running
through this material realm
and running through science
and infinite other dimensions.
But when I think about
it is the great mystery,
and that god is
essentially unknowable,
that helps me a lot.
So I don't I don't know who
or what god is specifically,
but that was a really
helpful bridge for me.
AUDIENCE: You've played
a number of unique roles.
I mean, I loved you
on "The Office,"
but I really also liked you
on "Six Feet Under" as well.
I was wondering if there
was something specific
that you look for when you're
considering taking on a role.
RAINN WILSON: It's kind of
this way for all actors--
do you respond to it?
You read the role,
and does it just
touch you or move
you in some way?
Does it affect you?
Part of what the book is
about, "The Bassoon King,"
is why I always play
these weird outsiders,
and I'm really drawn to playing
these weird, outsider roles.
I wouldn't know how to play a
popular guy, or a well-balanced
individual.
I don't connect.
I don't know how to do it.
Actually, I'd like to try
some time to see if I could.
That would be really
difficult for me.
So it is a kind of
an instinct thing.
As you've been acting for
many years, you kind of know.
Maybe it's the same
in the tech world,
if you're offered a
challenge in the tech world,
and you're kind of like,
oh, I like that challenge.
And I know how to do that.
I don't know specifically
how to do it,
but I know that I could
do something really cool
in that direction.
And it's the same thing
that happens as an actor.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
That's a great answer.
RAINN WILSON: They
were all great answers.
[LAUGHTER]
RAINN WILSON: Anything else, or
should we would call it a day?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I think we've
got one more in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rainn.
You recently just finished
writing a book, obviously,
so you have a little
free chunk of time.
Do you have a favorite TV show
right now that is currently on?
RAINN WILSON: "Silicon Valley."
For real, I love
"Silicon Valley."
It really makes me laugh.
It's so funny.
And I just was
chuckling about Hooli
as I was walking
through your campus.
It's just making
me laugh so much.
I love "Game of Thrones."
There's a lot of great stuff.
A lot of great stuff
going on on TV right now.
Comedy, not so much.
Comedy's tough.
I'm having a hard
time finding comedies
that actually make me laugh.
I like "Veep" a lot too.
There's a few out there,
but they're hard to find.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Rainn, thank you
so much for coming to Google,
for talking to us about
"The Bassoon King."
It was really lovely.
And we are looking forward to
getting to meet you and get
signatures of the book.
RAINN WILSON: Awesome.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]